While opium itself has been commonly used
since at least 3400 BC, heroin is a relatively
new invention, derived from opium.
Heroin, more technically known as diacetylmorphine,
was first synthesized in 1874 by chemist Charles
Romley Alder Wright, working at St. Mary’s
Hospital Medical School in London, England.
He discovered the drug after playing around
with mixing morphine with various acids.
Specifically, he created it after boiling
acetic anhydride with anhydrous morphine alkaloid
for a few hours, which resulted in what we
now commonly call heroin.
After running a few experiments with it on
animals, though, he abandoned his work on
the drug.
Twenty three years later, a man named Felix
Hoffman, working at Bayer, in Germany, managed
to independently synthesize Heroin when he
was trying to produce codeine.
This new derivative of opium was found to
be significantly more potent than morphine
and so Heinrich Dreser, head of the pharmacological
laboratory at Bayer, decided they should move
forward with it, rather than another drug
they had recently created (Aspirin).
It should be noted that Dreser was apparently
well aware of Wright having synthesized Heroin
23 years before, but despite this, he claimed
heroin was an original Bayer product and by
early 1898, they began the animal testing
phase of the product, testing it primarily
on rabbits and frogs.
They next moved on to testing it on people,
primarily workers at Bayer, including Heinrich
Dreser himself.
After successful trials, Heroin was presented
to the Congress of German Naturalists and
Physicians as more or less a miracle drug
that was “10 times” more effective than
codeine as a cough medicine and worked even
better than morphine as a pain killer.
He also stated that it had almost no toxic
effects including being completely non-addictive.
Dreser particularly pushed Heroin as the drug
of choice for treating asthma, bronchitis,
tuberculosis, and phthisis.
If it seems odd to you that he should push
Heroin as a cough medicine, over its pain
killing effects, it should be noted that at
the time tuberculosis and pneumonia were among
the world’s leading causes of death and
one of the leading methods to treat this was
using codeine, which is fairly addictive given
regular use.
Because Heroin worked well as a sedative and
respiration depressor, it did indeed work
extremely well as a type of cough medicine
and allowed people affected by debilitating
coughs to finally be able to get some proper
rest, free from coughing fits.
Further, because it was marketed as non-addictive,
unlike morphine or codeine, it was initially
seen as a major medical breakthrough.
Just one year after its release, Heroin became
a world-wide hit, despite it not actually
being marketed directly to the public, but
rather simply to physicians.
Heroin was soon sold in a variety of forms:
mixed in cough syrup; made into tablets; mixed
in a glycerin solution as an elixir; and put
into water-soluble heroin salts, among others.
At the end of this first year, it was popularly
sold in over 23 countries with Bayer producing
around one ton of it in that year.
Obviously, it quickly became apparent that
Bayer’s claims of the drug not being addictive
were completely false, with reports popping
up within months of its widespread release.
Despite this, it continued to sell well in
the medical field.
Finally, in 1913, after the number of Heroin
addicts began to skyrocket and it became likely
that it would shortly be banned in many countries,
Bayer decided to stop producing
the drug.
The originally trademarked name of Heroin
is thought to derive the German word “heroisch”
(heroic), due to the way the workers who tested
Heroin on themselves reported that it made
them feel.
Bayer ultimately lost the trademark for Heroin
in a few key markets at the same time they
were forced to give up their trademark on
Aspirin, thanks to WWI.
During WWI, Bayer’s assets, including their
trademark rights, in the U.S. and the Triple
Entente allies (UK, France, and Russia) were
confiscated and it became common to simply
refer to all brands of the drug as “Aspirin”
in those countries, among others.
Finally, after the signing of the Treaty of
Versailles, Bayer officially lost their trademarks
on Heroin and Aspirin in the U.S., France,
Russia, and the UK.
Interestingly, one of the common early uses
of Heroin was to help treat people who were
addicted to morphine, even though Heroin ultimately
proved to be more addictive.
Humorously, when morphine was first isolated
from opium in 1805, one of its early uses
was as a “non-addictive” drug to treat
people who were addicted to opium.
Felix Hoffman didn’t just help introduce
Heroin to the world, in 1897, he also was
one of the first people to synthesize a version
of something called salicyclic acid.
His version, though, didn’t have the extreme
negative stomach pain side effects normally
associated with that particular chemical.
“His” drug, acetylsalicyclic acid, is
more commonly known as aspirin.
Hoffman was not technically the first to synthesize
aspirin.
That distinction goes to French chemist Charles
Freferic Gerhardt who did it in 1853.
However, Gerhardt’s method resulted in an
unstable and impure form of aspirin.
Hoffman’s method had no such deficiencies,
though others had also managed to achieve
this feat before Hoffmann (resulting in numerous
lawsuits being filed against Bayer over this
after they introduced Aspirin).
The salicyclic acid aspirin is derived from
actually has been used for medicinal purposes
for thousands of years.
This chemical is naturally found in the bark
of a Willow tree.
Indeed, Hippocrates himself somewhere between
460 BC and 377 BC described a powder from
the Willow tree used to treat symptoms such
as headaches various types of pain, fever,
etc.
When aspirin was first recommended to Dreser
for Bayer to move forward with, he rejected
it, stating “The product has no value”.
Today, over 40 billion tablets of aspirin
are consumed annually.
Once Heroin’s star began to fall as people
began to realize how addictive it was, he
revisited his decision on Aspirin, which quickly
became Bayer’s best selling product.
After Heinrich Dreser left Bayer, he once
again is thought to have picked Heroin over
Aspirin, this time to his doom when he eventually
died of a stroke.
It is rumored that in his waning years, he
began taking heroin daily, rather than aspirin,
to treat his health problems.
What is ironical about this, of course, is
that a daily dose of aspirin may well have
prevented his stroke.
Both morphine and codeine were isolated from
opium in the same year, 1805, with morphine
being reported to be about ten times as potent
as opium itself.
As such, it quickly became one of the more
popular medicinal and recreational drugs in
many places in the world, particularly the
United States where it was used very commonly
as a pain reliever.
When heroin is orally ingested, its effects
are drastically reduced due to the fact that
it is converted to morphine when it is metabolized
by your body.
This may partially explain why the addictive
effects of heroin were not instantly apparent,
as is often the case with modern methods junkies
use to partake in this drug which result in
it being able to cross the blood-brain barrier
extremely quickly.
Today there are an estimated 15-20 million
people who are addicted to heroin.
While heroin is outlawed in most countries
in the world, it is still not so uncommonly
used medicinally in the UK for treating various
things such as for post-caesarian section
and other post-surgery pain.
It’s also used to help relieve pain in cancer
patients and for others who have chronic pain.
However, in recent years this usage has begun
to tail off, in favor of other drugs, such
as morphine.
Today, medical use of heroin in the UK accounts
for an estimated 95% of the legal usage of
heroin in the world.
Bayer was started by Friedrich Bayer and Johann
Friedrich Weskott in 1863 as a chemical company
making various paints, rather than pharmaceuticals.
Another major company today that started out
making dyes and now is famous for making something
completely different is Crayola.
Aspirin is thought to have significantly contributed
to the death toll in the 1918 flu epidemic
due to the fact that high doses of aspirin
can be toxic and these high doses can lead
to fluid build up in the lungs, upping the
chance of infection.
Bayer had their legacy significantly tarnished
during WWII when they became part of the Farben
German chemical company conglomerate that
is known to have used slave labor during WWII,
including managing slave labor camps.
Further, Farben was the group that manufactured
Zyklon B. Why is this important?
Because Zyklon B was the cyanide based pesticide
used in the Nazi gas chambers.
Bayer was forced to separate from Farben after
WWII.
One of Bayer’s executive officers during
WWII, Fritz ter Meer, who was the chairman
of Bayer’s supervisory board, was tried
and convicted during the Nuremberg War Crimes
Tribunal and sentenced to seven years in prison.
He reportedly was involved in various experiments
done at Auschwitz on human subjects.
Specifically, the charges he was convicted
of were: “guilty of count two, plunder and
spoliation, and count three, slavery and mass
murder.”
Bayer currently grosses around $45 billion
per year, with about $2 billion per year of
that as profit.
They also have well over 100,000 employees.